okay so I'd like to talk to you about a
symbol that means a lot to me means a
lot in terms of the work that I do which
is related to nanoscience and so one of
the fundamental symbols or one of the
fundamental quantities related to a
we're visits it's wavelength lambda or
its frequency nu so that's spelt and you
it comes from the Greek and it's that
the Greek symbol nu looks looks like
that that again is another convention
that these symbols have been used
alphabet a gamma nu Epsilon its
historical they've been introduced by
various physicists along the way so the
other symbol that is used is is actually
F and that's in the more recent
textbooks including our first-year
physics textbook you'll see F use more
more than you don't quite know the
reason for that I quite light nu myself
but FS only used a little more I think
perhaps the best way so if I bring out
the trusty guitar here so frequency when
I plug this this string at string
vibrates back and forth at a certain
rate per second there are so many
vibrations per second that sets the air
molecules into motion and then they in
turn very back and forth and they
vibrate back and forth on ryojun so the
key thing with frequency is that's a
relatively low frequency that's a
relatively high frequency and all you're
doing there is changing the number of
times per second that string moves up
and down you can think of it all in
terms of sound waves but you can also
think of it in terms of light waves so
what with with light like that we can
see in this room or light coming from
distant stars that is actually another
wave but in this case what it is is a
wave of the electromagnetic field okay
so what you have is a basically a field
that's vibrating back and forth and
what's interesting is in this case that
they're fast without field vibrates back
and forth then the different you see a
difference in color and this goes all
the way not just in terms of the visible
spectrum that we can see where you go
from red to blue so red is a relatively
low frequency blue is a much higher
frequency but it also goes all the way
down
to infrared actually down to much lower
frequencies all the way up to x-rays
which are very very hard very high
frequency lots of vibrations per second
if we place it a guess in the context of
radio waves where because people are
interested I've heard of kilohertz and
megahertz and when we're talking about I
guess the key thing is there is the
vibrations on the atomic scale we're
talking about at least a million times
more a million to a billion times
greater level of frequencies so these
things are flipping back and forth very
very very many more times a second than
your conventional radio wave
the interesting thing is that the
smaller you make it the larger the
frequency becomes so if I can grab a
ruler and it's a really useful one so
let's if we let's do a really simple
demo so we've got something which here
is 25 centimeters long so if we vibrate
that we see that it oscillates it
wobbles back and forth at a few times
every second something like that so
that's its resonant frequency that's the
frequency it likes to to vibrate at and
then so if we make it a little bit
shorter so you know so it's 15
centimeters you'll see that the resonant
frequency has increased we make it a
little bit shorter still now we're down
to nine centimeters you can see that
dies out a little bit quicker but you
can see that the frequency is as much as
is greater and if you imagine trying to
make that really really really really
really small so this was only a few a
fraction of a millimeter you know a few
tenths or a few hundreds of a millimeter
then the frequency actually goes up to
tens or maybe hundreds of kilohertz
thousands of Hertz and then if you go
those extra few steps those extra few
orders of magnitude as we see for powers
of 10 down to the range of the
individual atoms and molecules then
we're going into the terahertz regime
where you've got a bit of sorry a
million million Hertz 10 to the 12 10 to
the power of 12 volts we have this
picture of atoms and molecules being and
electrons and small particles being like
billiard balls when in fact or not
really at the quantum level in the nanos
in the Nano world what we have are
basically matter waves so matter stops
behaving like these
billiard balls we have this picture up
in our heads and actually spread out and
they have a way of associated with them
and what's remarkable is there is the
fundamental physics of waves the same
type of physics that you apply to the
guitar to a large extent you can also
apply to the behavior of matter at the
quantum level up until the early years
of the 20th century the classical
picture was that atoms is just a
basically a hard particle like a little
sphere but in fact what it looks more
like is a wave that looks like that okay
so this has certainly got a it's got an
extent but you can see that instead of
being just one being at one position
which we could define here if we put X
on this axis again so this is the
position instead of just finding the
particle at one position on the x axis
we see that it spreads out it's got this
wave like wave-like character for me and
I think for many scientists nano
scientists this is one of the key iconic
images not just of nanoscience in the
20th century but of science in general
it's it's it is really a huge impact and
it's incredibly visceral it really is
visceral this particular image what we
have here the work was carried out by a
group in IBM al-madinah and in the US
and what they've done it they've
positioned 50 atoms 50 iron atoms on a
copper surface so this is an underlying
copper surface and if they've used
something we'll talk about Liat or I
guess a scanning tunneling microscope
which is a sharp basically a sharp tip
you bring it in close to a surface you
move it around and you can almost
literally push these atoms around and so
they form this ring of 50 atoms that in
itself is a wonderful feat of atomic
scale engineering but that's not what
makes this image so beautiful what makes
this image so beautiful is study it's
like you took a stone and you dropped it
in the center here and you can see these
ripples of water electron waves
spreading out and what it is is it's
really visual and as I said visceral
evidence of the wave-like nature of the
electron because the electrons on this
particular surface spread out like a
basically
a sea of electrons and as you're
dropping effectively dropping a stone
into that sea of electrons and what's
remarkable is that you can use
undergraduate first and second well
second year undergraduate quantum
mechanics to actually work out the
separations of these rings the spacings
of these rings